.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Fünf Tage, 200 km, bis -20 °C.
Mit dem Husky-Gespann
quer durch die Wildnis Lapplands.
Vier Frauen und ein Mann
erfüllen sich einen Traum.
* Treibende, mystische Musik
mit Gesang *
20 Std. Dunkelheit am Tag.
Eine Reise,
die sie an ihre Grenzen bringt ...
... aber auch
ihr Leben verändern wird.
Es ist eine so grosse Bereicherung.
Das ist prägend.
Das ist etwas vom Besten, was ich
in meinem Leben je getan habe.
Es ist einfach alles perfekt
und es tut mir so gut.
Genau das, was ich nötig hatte.
Es ist eigentlich Wahnsinn,
innerhalb von vier Tagen
eine solche Bindung
erleben zu können.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Fünf Tage zuvor.
Das Abenteuer startet
100 km nördlich des Polarkreises
auf der Husky Ranch
von Juho Ylipiessa
im finnischen Kurtakko.
Es ist Anfang Dezember 2019.
Gemeinsam mit seiner Frau Hanna
betreut Juho hier 29 Alaskan Huskys.
Hanna wird in den nächsten Tagen
auf die Ranch aufpassen müssen,
ihr Mann Juho wird mit den
Schweizer Abenteurern unterwegs sein.
Die Bedingungen auf den Trails
sind gut.
Ich meine, ich würde es lieber
ein bisschen kälter haben.
Aber ich bin zufrieden,
dass die Seen gefroren sind.
Und die Eis- oder Schneeschicht
ist immerhin 40 cm dick.
Die Trails sind wirklich gut.
Das ist nicht selbstverständlich
für diese Jahreszeit.
Juho und Hanna
haben seit 2009 Schlittenhunde.
Juho fährt mit ihnen zwei bis drei
Langstreckenrennen pro Winter.
Doch meistens ist er in dieser
Jahreszeit mit Touristen unterwegs.
Fünftägige Touren
sind aber eher selten.
Die Schweizer Gruppe ist unterdessen
in der Dunkelheit Lapplands
angekommen.
Die vier Frauen und ein Mann
haben sich bis jetzt nicht gekannt.
Eine HR-Managerin,
eine Physiotherapeutin,
eine Software-Testmanagerin,
der Brunnenmeister aus Giswil
und eine Psychologin und Mutter
von drei kleinen Kindern.
# Chumm, mir waged s Abentüür,
z obe hocke mir chli ums Füür.
Sie haben sich auf einen Aufruf
von "SRF DOK" gemeldet.
Was sie verbindet:
der Wunsch, für fünf Tage
aus ihrem Alltag auszubrechen.
Und die Liebe zu Hunden
und zur Natur Lapplands.
Mach einen Engel!
- Die erste Schneeschlacht.
Bevor es losgeht: eine letzte Nacht
in einem warmen Bett in Ylläsjärvi.
* Sanfte Musik *
Am nächsten Tag:
statt Schnee und Minustemperaturen:
Regen.
Heute sollte die Tour beginnen.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Juho hat alles vorbereitet.
Oh, wow!
- Good morning.
(Alle) Good morning.
Ihr seid also meine Gruppe.
Hallo.
Hi, I'm Juho.
- Barbara.
Silvia.
- Juho. Nice to meet you.
Armin.
Martina. Nice to meet you.
- Juho.
Willkommen auf der Husky Ranch.
Ich wünschte,
wir hätten besseres Wetter.
Ich weiss,
ihr wollt die Hunde treffen,
aber zuerst werden wir euch
bessere Kleider besorgen.
Und dann werfen wir
einen Blick auf die Karte,
wo wir in den nächsten fünf Tagen
unterwegs sein werden.
Gehen wir rein,
der Regen ist schrecklich.
Habt ihr so was schon gemacht?
Wie viel Erfahrung habt ihr?
Keine Erfahrung.
- Keine Erfahrung.
Halbtagestouren.
Okay, die schönen, die einfachen.
Die mache ich normalerweise auch.
Tagestouren.
Eine einstündige Tour.
Okay. Also wenigstens
ein bisschen Erfahrung.
Das Ganze ist einfach.
Wenn ihr Hunde und die Natur liebt,
dann ist das schon mal
ein guter Start.
Denkt daran, wir werden weit fahren.
Deshalb müssen wir
als Team zusammenbleiben.
Du darfst das Team nicht verlieren.
Punkt.
Wir fahren zuerst 5 km durch Wald.
Dann kommen wir
in dieses grosse Naturreservat.
Das grösste Sumpfgebiet Europas.
(Deutsch) Der grösste Sumpf -
korrekt so?
Die Tour beginnt 100 km nördlich
des Polarkreises in Finnland.
Von Kurtakko führt sie am ersten Tag
35 km durch das grösste Sumpfgebiet
Europas in die Wälder Lapplands.
Am zweiten Tag folgen 46 km,
am dritten Tag weitere 38 km
mit dem steilen Anstieg
auf den Aalistunturi.
Und am vierten Tag folgt
die Königsetappe mit über 50 km,
den gleichen Weg zurück ...
... bevor es am fünften Tag
wieder zur Ranch geht.
Inzwischen
hat es aufgehört zu regnen.
Die Teilnehmer
lernen ihre Hunde kennen.
Let's go and see the dogs.
- Yes!- Juhu!
(Barbara)
That's the best part for us.
(Juho) Alle sind nett,
ihr könnt überall hingehen.
Keiner beisst.
Eto ist yours as well.
Das wird dein Hund sein, Silvia.
Er wird
direkt vor dem Schlitten laufen.
Er ist stark.
Mayday wird in der Mitte sein.
Das ist die Mutter von Mayday.
Die schwarze, Irny.
Ich werde sie nicht
ins erste Team nehmen,
sondern irgendwo in der Mitte.
Sie wollen nur noch los. Das ist
für sie ein Zeichen zum Aufbruch:
wenn Leute in dieser Kleidung
hier stehen.
Mayday.
Ja, sie hören auf den Namen.
Mayday ist erst einjährig und war
noch nie auf einer so langen Tour.
White Socks
könntest du auch heissen.
Armin.
Ist das einer von deinen?
Das ist Ballack,
dieser schwere Hund.
Der Monsterhund!
Der passt zu mir,
das hat er gecheckt.
Armin der Brunnenmeister
hat den grossen, starken Ballack
im Team.
Es ist sehr berührend.
Dass einem ein Wesen so nah ist.
* Lockere Musik *
Es sind alle sehr herzig.
Dieser hier ist sehr ruhig.
Der andere ist ganz verspielt
und rennt rum.
Es ist spannend, wie man
die verschiedenen Typen spürt.
Charaktere wie bei uns Menschen,
sehr verschieden.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Jede und jeder wird während der Tour
für sein eigenes Gespann
mit fünf Hunden verantwortlich sein.
Zuerst heisst es, Schlitten packen
mit Essen für sich und die Hunde,
dem eigenen Gepäck
und dem Campingmaterial.
Jeder Schlitten
wiegt so bis zu 60 kg.
Sie bekommen erste Instruktionen
auf der Farm.
Auf der Tour müssen sie
die Hunde versorgen, Camps aufbauen
und v.a. die Kontrolle
über das Gespann nicht verlieren.
So.
Wir gehen
die Fahrinstruktionen durch.
Wenn wir unterwegs sind,
gibt es drei einfache Zeichen.
Das hier heisst langsamer.
Ihr bleibt mit dem Fuss
auf der Bremsplatte.
Das heisst Stopp.
Steht auf die Metallbremse!
Und wenn wir angehalten haben,
müsst ihr auf der Bremse bleiben.
Wenn die Pause länger ist,
dann setzt ihr sogar den Bremsanker.
Aber auch der hält nicht sicher.
Auch wenn wir anhalten,
behaltet ihn im Auge!
Und wenn ihr runterfallt,
was passieren könnte ...
Das passiert immer wieder.
Wenn ihr also so runterfallt
und hier hängt, lasst nicht los!
Das ist die wichtigste Regel.
Lasst den Schlitten nicht los!
Wartet, bis die Hunde anhalten!
Steht wieder auf die Bremse,
atmet tief ein und fahrt weiter.
Putzt eure Kleider ab,
dann wird niemand wissen,
dass ihr runtergefallen seid.
* Lachen *
Siehst du?
- That's important, don't lose face.
So, wir spannen zuerst
die Leader ein.
Und denkt dran,
diese kleinen Kreaturen
werden die Seile durchbeissen,
wenn ihr nicht aufpasst.
Also schaut immer wieder,
dass die Hunde noch da sind.
Irny ist die schwarze da hinten.
* Wildes Bellen *
Armin, lass die Hunde nicht raus!
Don't let them run away.
Tür zu!
Zieh ihm das Geschirr im Zwinger an
und komm mit einem Hund raus.
Öffne nicht die Tür,
sonst rennen sie raus.
Dräng sie zurück!
Na, jetzt geht es bald los.
Gut so?
Completely.
Perfekt so.
Ihr müsst euch kennenlernen, wie?
Hey, aber seid lieb!
Lieb sein.
Ihr müsst lieb sein.
Kaum sind die Hunde eingespannt,
wollen sie losrennen.
Juho versucht,
alles unter Kontrolle zu behalten.
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Dann endlich: Juho gibt das Zeichen
für den Start der Tour.
Die Reihenfolge ist klar definiert,
jeder hat seine Position.
Doch ausgerechnet
Bobfahrerin Michelle
kann ihre Hunde
nicht mehr zurückhalten.
Hey, löse deine Bremsen
nicht zu früh.
Kontrollier dein Team,
stell dich auf die Bremse!
* Lautes Bellen und Jaulen *
* Treibende Musik *
Dann endlich geht es los.
Es ist 12 Uhr.
Herrlich ruhig.
Die Hunde trippeln.
Das ist
eine wahnsinnig schnelle Piste.
Ich muss immer
leicht auf der Bremse stehen.
* Mystische, treibende Musik *
Und da ist es,
das Gefühl von Freiheit.
Davon haben sie alle geträumt.
Eine Stimmung - speziell, mystisch.
* Mystische, treibende Musik *
Die Tage im Dezember sind kurz,
nur 4 Std. Dämmerlicht.
Schon nach 14 Uhr
verschwindet das Licht.
Noch bevor die Dunkelheit
hereinbricht ein erster Stopp.
Essenspause, auch für die Tiere.
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut.
15 km haben wir schon.
Mittagspause.
Auf Silvia
wird Juho ein Auge werfen.
Vor vier Jahren bekam sie
die Diagnose Parkinson.
Die Tour stellt für sie
eine besondere Herausforderung dar.
Es ist traumhaft, ein super Start,
superschönes Wetter.
Es ist einfach ... geil.
Ich habe grosse Freude,
ich bin happy.
Dank Medikamenten führt sie
ein weitgehend normales Leben.
Ihr Arzt gab grünes Licht
für die Tour.
Okay, come to this side.
We're going to take
those dogs closer.
Pass auf, dass die Hunde
nicht deine Leine durchbeissen.
Fantastisch!
Man kann es mit Worten nicht
beschreiben, einfach wunderschön.
Es ist, als würde man
über den Schnee fliegen.
Hier in Lappland
gibt es diese Weite,
die wir in der Schweiz nicht haben.
Kannst du uns bitte helfen, Juho?
Das Seil muss einige Male rum,
dann der Knoten.
Noch klappt nicht alles.
Geduld ist nicht meine Stärke.
Am Anfang ging es so schnell,
sie sind einfach los und dann ...
Aber mit der Zeit lief es besser.
Sie haben unglaublich viel Kraft,
das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Sei vorsichtig mit den Fingern.
Sie lieben diese Würste.
Okay.
Das ist fast schon gemein.
So, hier.
Die Hunde erhalten
ein Stück gefrorene Wurst.
* Bellen, Fiepen *
Viel Arbeit, an die sich
das Team noch gewöhnen muss.
Ich nehme jetzt mal wieder ...
... meine Drogen.
Meine Medikamente.
Oh.
So.
Ich muss sie regelmässig,
zu bestimmten Zeiten einnehmen.
Sonst bricht mein Dopaminspiegel ein
und dann kann ich mich
nicht mehr bewegen.
Ich bin jetzt schon
ziemlich langsam.
Das ist das Dopamin,
das mir durch die Krankheit fehlt.
Ich habe so eine Box,
die ich jeden Tag vorbereite.
So weiss ich immer,
welche ich wann einnehmen muss.
So.
Die Hunde wollen weiter.
Sie haben erst den halben Weg
zurückgelegt. Keine Distanz für sie.
* Treibende Musik *
Silvia erfüllt sich
mit der Tour einen Traum.
Wegen der fortschreitenden Krankheit
weiss sie nicht,
wie lange solche Abenteuer für sie
körperlich noch möglich sein werden.
* Treibende Musik *
Es ist zwar erst 15 Uhr,
doch schon stockfinster.
Alle ahnen, dass noch einiges
auf sie zukommen wird.
* Treibende Musik *
Armin, der Brunnenmeister. macht
den Schluss in der Schlittenkolonne.
Seine Hunde sind die kräftigsten,
aber auch die wildesten.
Nach 3 Std. Fahrt gegen 17 Uhr:
das erste Nachtlager mitten im Wald.
Hier sind wir.
Camping site.
Hier ist es schön.
Sucht euch alle einen Baum.
Na?
Ihr seid ein gutes Team.
Doch einer fehlt - Armin.
Es herrscht etwas Chaos.
Ein Hundeschlitten ist weg.
Echt?
- Ja, Armin ist irgendwie ...
Er ist auf den falschen Weg geraten
und verschwunden.
Zum Glück passierte der Fehler
so nah am Etappenziel.
So hat Juho
Armins Gespann schnell gefunden.
Sie sind
auf die falsche Seite abgebogen.
Ich liess etwas Abstand,
weil sie so viel Power haben,
dann kam die Abzweigung
und sie gingen nach rechts.
Ich hatte keine Chance.
Ich hätte nach links gehen sollen.
Ich bin dort hochgefahren,
dann sind wir umgekehrt
und jetzt sind wir zurück.
Nun beginnt die Arbeit im Camp.
Bevor wir für uns schauen,
versorgen wir die Hunde.
Wir geben ihnen halbgefrorene Wurst,
damit sie schon
etwas im Bauch haben,
bevor das richtige Nachtessen kommt.
Gut.
Ja, fein.
Ballack, hier.
Ja.
(Lachend) Das schmeckt ihnen.
Jeder Hund sucht sich
sein eigenes Plätzchen.
Du bist schon etwas müde, nicht?
Unsere Lady.
Sie hat selbst
das Heu herangescharrt
und hat sich hingelegt
und eingerollt.
Das ist ihr Bett,
von dem sie nicht mehr aufsteht.
Als ich das Geschirr abnahm,
bewegte sie sich ganz wenig,
aber hier geht sie nicht mehr weg.
Silvia präpariert
den Hundehauptgang.
Fleisch klopfen.
Zu Hause macht das mein Freund. Er
muss immer das Fleisch zubereiten.
Das Fleisch ist noch gefroren
und muss zuerst aufgetaut werden.
Juho muss alles kontrollieren.
Es sieht schon fast essbar aus.
Sie brauchen ja
auch noch was zu beissen.
Die Kiste muss voll Wasser sein.
Zuerst kommt das Fleisch rein,
etwa zwei Drittel voll.
Dann füllt ihr es bis oben
mit heissem Wasser auf,
sonst wird das nicht weich.
(Armin) Barbara muss einfädeln.
- Ich bin drin.
Unser gemütliches Zuhause.
Tretet ein!
* Mehrstimmiges Heulen *
Was ist das?
Einer hat angefangen und ...
Ich glaube, es gibt Essen.
- Ah, das Fleisch.
Ich bin stolz auf uns.
Wie lange dauerte es - 5 Min.?
Vielleicht 10 Min.
Aber wir waren schnell.
(Juho) Gib das ruhig
auch den grossen Jungs!
Und wenn ihr ihnen
das Essen hinstellt, passt auf.
Exactly.
Kommt von einer Seite!
Perfekt.
They know how to do it.
Abenteuer Lappland:
Es bedeutet nicht nur Romantik,
sondern auch viel Verantwortung.
Gegen 21 Uhr
die erste Rast des Tages.
Ich geniesse es.
Ich geniesse es in vollen Zügen.
Es ist ...
Ich hoffte, dass es so sein würde,
und ich bin überzeugt,
dass es noch besser wird.
Am Anfang muss man sich
einfach noch etwas finden.
Das hat man gemerkt.
Aber einige Dinge haben super
geklappt, die haben wir im Griff.
Morgen teilen wir alles etwas mehr
auf und helfen mehr mit den Hunden,
dann läuft es.
Als wir hier waren, spürte ich die
ganze Anspannung und Freude und ...
Ich wurde dann auch
richtig emotional.
Diese ganze Freude, was wir alles
erlebt haben. Jetzt sind wir hier.
Aber irgendwie auch:
"Was mache ich jetzt?"
"Was mache ich mit den Hunden?
Was mache ich mit dem Gepäck?"
Am Anfang fühlte ich mich
auch ein bisschen hilflos.
Aber ich glaube, in den
nächsten Tagen weiss man dann,
was man zu tun hat,
wie man es tun soll.
Ich bin froh,
dass ich so gut durchhalten konnte.
Ich hatte grosse Angst davor,
nicht durchhalten zu können.
Aber jetzt habe ich ein gutes Gefühl
für die nächsten Tage.
Ich war sehr beeindruckt,
wie sie das mit
dem Gemeinschaftszelt gemacht haben.
Ich habe mein Team gefüttert
und dann habe ich gedacht:
"Soll ich hingehen und ihnen sagen,
sie sollen das Zelt aufstellen?"
Aber es war schon da.
Das Füttern müssen wir
noch ein bisschen verbessern.
Da ist noch unsere Schwachstelle.
Aber für das Zelt
gibt es schon mal fünf Punkte.
Es gibt diese heilige Regel,
dass man nicht isst,
bevor die Hunde Futter haben.
Sie haben das nicht gern
und werden dich nicht mehr mögen.
* Lachen *
* Sanfte, mystische Musik *
Es ist morgens um 6.30 Uhr.
Die Nacht war kalt.
(Silvia) Guten Morgen.
Was für eine Nacht!
(Heiser) Super Stimme.
Ich muss pinkeln und dann
Feuer für das Hundefutter machen.
Heisses Wasser für Kaffee, Tee,
die Thermoskannen -
einfach für alles.
Einfach mal etwas Warmes.
Habt ihr gut geschlafen?
Die Hunde warten bereits hungrig
auf ihr Fressen.
Doch die Abenteurer
nehmen es gemütlich.
Zum Missfallen von Juho.
Der Ofen war zwar an,
aber das muss schneller gehen.
Es sollte immer
jemand hier sein und schauen,
dass ständig Schnee schmilzt,
dass es immer Feuer hat.
Es ist der erste Morgen.
Darum lasse ich das noch durchgehen.
Aber das hier
müsste erste Priorität haben.
Und ich gebe euch noch einen Tipp:
Es ist schön warm hier am Ofen.
Kein schlechter Platz,
wenn du aus dem kalten Zelt kommst.
Vorsichtig, damit ihr nicht die
ganze Stunde Arbeit zunichte macht.
Die Hunde kommen zuerst
und dann die Teilnehmer.
Und jede Minute Verzögerung am Morgen
bedeutet weniger Tageslicht
während der Tour.
Das müsst ihr immer als Erstes
machen, das Wasser schmelzen.
Erst nachher geht ihr auf Toilette
und putzt die Zähne.
Der Ofen hier muss immer brennen,
denn das Schmelzen dauert lange.
So, jetzt machen wir noch Kaffee,
damit Armin aufwacht.
Barbara, die dreifache Mutter,
ist es, die heute anpackt.
Darauf habe ich mich sehr gefreut -
die Hunde zu versorgen.
Abends, morgens, immer wieder.
(Silvia)
Du hast deine Aufgabe gefunden.
Ich mache das sehr gerne. Das
ist vielleicht die Mutter in mir.
Wenn ich keine Kinder
versorgen kann, dann eben Hunde.
So vermisse ich
meine Kinder weniger.
Nur wenig. Ja?
Die Hunde bekommen rohes Fleisch
mit hohem Fettgehalt,
dazu kommen noch
getrocknete Proteinstücke.
An diese Routine
müssen sich alle erst gewöhnen,
denn sie haben
die Verantwortung für die Tiere.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
* Bellen *
9.30 Uhr.
Eigentlich wollte Juho
bereits unterwegs sein.
Die Hunde sind unruhig,
sie wollen los.
Die Hunde sind sehr aufgeladen,
sie wollen rennen.
Ich rechne damit,
dass irgendetwas passiert.
Damit alle für den restlichen Tag
noch ein Team haben,
bleibe ich hier,
um sie allenfalls zu stoppen.
Und tatsächlich, Juhos Vorahnung
bewahrheitet sich rasch.
Hey, hey!
Zuhinterst bei Armin
herrscht Aufregung.
* Bellen und Jaulen *
Hey, hey!
Armins Rüden Ballack und Cooper
geraten in einen Kampf.
Hey, hey!
* Wildes Bellen *
Wir hatten hier
gerade einen Kampf.
Du musst strenger sein.
Kann ich immer dazwischengehen?
Geh nicht mit den Händen rein,
wenn sie kämpfen.
Aber sag klar Stopp.
Du bist der Chef.
Es dauert alles so lange,
die Hunde werden nervös.
Ich habe eben zu Armin gesagt, dass
er sie nicht streiten lassen darf.
Du musst streng sein.
Wenn du spürst,
dass der Ton zu aggressiv wird,
musst du das sofort stoppen.
Wenn sie sich für 10 Min. anbrüllen,
kann es ausarten.
Hey, jetzt sind die beiden Starken
aufeinander losgegangen.
Das war ein richtiges Knäuel.
Ich wusste nicht, was ich tun soll.
Man muss brutal durchgreifen,
denn die beissen sich gegenseitig.
* Seufzen *
* Mystische Musik *
Dann endlich gegen 11 Uhr,
2 Std. zu spät,
geht es los in die zweite Etappe.
Du musst sie gehen lassen.
Go, go!
Die kriegen wir heute
schon noch müde.
Immer tiefer und tiefer
in die Wildnis Lapplands.
Achtung, Bäume.
* Spannungserzeugende Musik *
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Die Gruppe ist nach der Aufregung
des Morgens endlich unterwegs.
Hundeführer Juho hofft,
dass sich die Huskys beruhigen,
wenn sie endlich laufen können.
Und tatsächlich:
Friedlich zieht auch das Fünfer-
gespann des Brunnenmeisters Armin
durch die Abgeschiedenheit Finnlands.
Ihre Schlitten haben die
fünf Schweizer schon besser im Griff.
Jeder führt Proviant und Gepäck
selber mit, bis zu 60 kg.
* Helle, perlende Klänge *
Der erste Stopp
nach wenigen Kilometern.
Hund Cooper hat sich
beim Kampf am Morgen verletzt.
Sicherheitshalber
nimmt ihn Juho aus dem Gespann.
* Bellen, Jaulen *
Jetzt schont er ihn,
bis wir die grosse Pause haben,
und schaut,
denn er hat eine Verletzung am Lauf.
* Bellen, Jaulen *
Ich kann nicht viel sehen.
Die Wunde ist nicht gross,
nur ein Kratzer.
Nur ein Kratzer auf der Haut.
Und das
an unserem Unabhängigkeitstag!
Am 6. Dezember 1917
löste sich Finnland
aus der russischen Vorherrschaft.
Seither ist dieser Tag
der finnische Nationalfeiertag.
Juho verabreicht
dem verletzten Cooper eine Tablette
und gönnt dem Tier
eine Verschnaufpause.
Ich gebe ihm
entzündungshemmende Mittel.
Es ist wirklich
nur ein kleiner Schnitt.
Es sieht nicht schlimm aus.
Ich nehme ihn in meine Notfallkiste
auf den Schlitten
und wir schauen am Abend,
was wir machen.
Geht es ihm am Morgen nicht besser,
muss ihn jemand abholen kommen.
* Jaulen *
Ja, ja, Ballack.
Du hast Ballack,
mit ihm reichen auch vier Hunde.
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Mit 39 kg ist Ballack
der grösste Hund aus Juhos Rudel.
Schau, wie schön. Siehst du's?
Hei!
So orange, so ...
Schön, nicht?
Das tut bis weit hinein gut.
* Juchzen *
Immer weiter ...
... weg aus der Zivilisation ...
... weg von den Anforderungen
des Alltags.
* Helle, perlende Klänge *
Ja, ja.
Für Silvia bedeutet jeder Tag
eine neue Herausforderung
mit ihrer Parkinsonkrankheit.
Perfekt. Wie geht's dir, Silvia?
- Gut.
Good?
- Yes.
Das war wohl der schwierigste
Streckenabschnitt der ganzen Woche.
Ich weiss noch nicht so genau,
wie ich mein Gewicht einsetzen soll,
um richtig zu steuern.
Michelle, die Physiotherapeutin,
kümmert sich sofort um die Hunde.
* Jaulen *
Der starke Ballack und Armin freunden
sich langsam an und werden zum Team.
So können sie nichts mehr ziehen.
Sie können den Schlitten nicht
ziehen, wenn man sie rausnimmt.
Und wie geht es Cooper
im fahrenden Krankenzimmer?
Er war einfach zu vorwitzig.
Cooper ist ein Punk.
Er ist
ein anderthalbjähriger Frechdachs.
Normalerweise haben andere Hunde
Respekt vor Ballack.
Aber der hier war dumm genug,
Ballack herauszufordern.
Und natürlich hat er verloren.
- (Armin) Ist das sein Charakter?
Cooper ist noch jung und sucht noch
seinen Platz in der Hundehierarchie.
Diesen Luxus hat man nicht oft
im Leben, mit so schönen Tieren.
Mein Gefühl ist, ich konnte
schon eine Bindung aufbauen,
aber von ihnen her ist es ...
So stark ist es wohl nicht.
Aber sie freuen sich,
wenn man kommt und sie wertschätzt.
Ich liess gestern den ganzen Tag
Revue passieren und muss sagen,
ab den ersten 2-3 km
wurde ich recht emotional -
alles ... prasselte auf mich nieder.
Man fährt plötzlich einfach
mit seinem eigenen Schlitten
durch einen wunderschönen Wald,
es funktioniert alles,
man spürt eine ...
tiefe Zufriedenheit,
man ist glücklich.
Man ist völlig losgelöst von allem.
Natürlich,
die Umgebung trägt einiges dazu bei,
dass man nicht an den Alltag denkt.
* Entferntes Bellen *
Und Silvia?
Dass ich glücklich bin.
Ganz einfach.
Einfach einen Moment ...
Jetzt rührt es mich.
Die Krankheit zu vergessen.
Ich habe es fast vergessen.
Ich spüre nicht viel. Nur wenn ich
die Tabletten wieder nehmen muss.
Aber ich vergesse es völlig,
es ist nicht mehr im Vordergrund.
Es ist ... irgendwo weit hinten.
Das wünschte ich mir.
Und es ist super.
Ich bin extrem glücklich.
I'm so happy. Dabei ...
- (Juho) I can see it. Ich auch.
Ich vergesse meine Parkinson-Erkran-
kung, und das ist so wichtig. Danke!
Schon gut.
Und ich habe vergessen, dass du
diese Erkrankung überhaupt hast.
Wir fuhren diesen steilen Hügel
runter und ich dachte:
"Ist das wirklich Silvia?"
Ich bin eine Kämpferin.
Aufgeben ist keine Option.
Dieser Hügel war anspruchsvoller
als alles, was noch kommt.
Es kommen noch grössere Anstiege,
aber die sind viel einfacher.
Aufgeben kommt nicht infrage.
- Das ist die richtige Einstellung.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Juho hat wohl aus taktischen Gründen
etwas untertrieben
mit den bevorstehenden Anstrengungen.
Vor dem Team liegt
ein steiler Anstieg über 200 m.
Es ist gegen 15 Uhr
und bereits stockdunkel.
Jetzt kommt nochmals ein
grosser Anstieg, dann eine Abfahrt.
Wir fahren hoch, so schnell es geht,
stoppen oben nicht
und fahren wirklich langsam
hinunter, alle zusammen.
(Armin) Okay.
- I want to see everybody.
* Bellen *
* Abenteuerliche Trommelklänge *
* Juho ruft und pfeift Kommandos. *
(Juho) He, Frauen,
haltet die Augen offen!
* Abenteuerliche Trommelschläge *
Die Hunde sind stark,
doch bei so einem Anstieg
müssen die Teilnehmer mithelfen.
Sie dürfen dabei ihren Schlitten
auf keinen Fall verlieren.
Go! Komm.
Auch Armin bleibt
trotz besonders starkem Gespann
die Anstrengung nicht erspart.
Die ehemalige Profi-Bobfahrerin
Michelle ist voll in ihrem Element.
Wie früher - am liebsten
würde ich mehrmals hoch und runter,
es war unglaublich. Wahnsinn.
Das Tempo, Gewicht verlagern,
rechts, links, dann rennen - super.
Verrückt, was die leisten.
Und v.a. ...
... mit so vielen Kilos
hinten drauf.
Und sie wollen immer weiter,
wenn man wartet.
Das sind wilde Kerle.
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Jetzt trippeln sie wieder.
Achtung.
Armin war nicht immer Brunnenmeister.
Er hatte 30 Jahre lang
ein Sanitärheizungsgeschäft,
das er vor fünf Jahren
verkauft hatte,
um seinem Leben
eine neue Wende zu geben.
Jetzt haben wir den wiederdrin,
scheisse.
Ach.
Um 17 Uhr erreichen alle
das Nachtlager -
ohne weitere Zwischenfälle.
Ich bin gerade etwas traurig,
dass wir schon da sind -
wir hätten von mir aus
2-3 Std. weiterfahren können.
Es war so schön!
Tipptopp, voll cool!
Ich bin hellauf begeistert.
Langsam sitzen die Handgriffe,
und die Hunde werden sofort versorgt.
So.
Bravo, Mädchen.
Was für ein Durcheinander
ihr gemacht habt!
Gib die doppelte Menge Wurst.
- (Armin) Wirklich?
Ja, es war ein langer Tag
und es wird eine kalte Nacht.
Sie brauchen viel Energie. Und
dann füttern wir sie nach 1-2 Std.
(Silvia) Ich bin gespannt,
wie viele Kilometer das heute waren.
Barbara
ist für das Hundefleisch zuständig.
Ich zeige Euch, wo es Wasser gibt.
(Barbara) Wasser schöpfen
geht schneller als Schnee schmelzen.
Es kocht schon.
(Juho) Wir holen jetzt mehr Wasser.
- Wirklich? Aber der Topf ist heiss.
It's not that bad.
- Holt er es da hinten?
Ja. Ich gehe mit.
- Und ich hacke fröhlich weiter.
Ich bin
der Orientierungssinn in Person.
Juho zeigt Silvia,
wo er eine Quelle entdeckt hat.
Es gibt hier überall Wasser,
wir müssen nur klares finden.
Es schmeckt gut, solange
nicht zu viel Dreck reinkommt.
(Barbara)
Ah, wir müssten mehr haben.
(Englisch) Wir brauchen mehr.
(Juho) Ja, ich habe einige grosse
Behälter auf meinem Schlitten.
Es gibt auch eine kleine Quelle.
Hier hat es immer Wasser.
Wir können sogar
unser Trinkwasser von dort nehmen.
(Barbara) Wow.
Dann warten wir.
Ja, der Geschmack war gut,
nicht erdig.- Good.
Juho
schaut nach dem verletzten Cooper.
Ich bin fast sicher,
es sah am Anfang viel schlimmer aus,
als es war.
Es ist nur ein kleiner Schnitt.
Die Verletzung geht nicht tief,
nicht bis auf die Muskeln
oder das Fleisch.
Solange wir die Wunde sauber halten,
sollte er morgen laufen können.
Ich habe ihm
keine Schmerzmittel gegeben,
weil ich wissen wollte,
ob er Schmerzen hat und hinkt.
Mit den Medikamenten
würde er auf jeden Fall laufen.
Willst du was sagen?
Dieser Kerl hier ist elf Jahre alt
und schon locker 30'000 km
mit mir gelaufen.
About 30'000 km with me
on the trail.
Jetzt gibt's eine kleine Massage
für den alten Herrn,
gegen den steifen Rücken.
Ja, das ist der richtige Ort.
Nach Tagen wie diesen freuen sie
sich auf die heisse Fleischsuppe.
* Helle, perlende Klänge *
Juho, meinst du,
die Hunde kennen uns schon?
Ich glaube,
die Hunde gewöhnen sich an euch.
Es ist schon der zweite Tag.
Sie sind immer um dieselbe Person,
die ihnen das Fressen gibt.
(Barbara) Ha, dann kennen sie mich!
(Juho) Ja, bei ihnen
läuft vieles über das Essen.
Sie funktionieren relativ einfach.
Wer sie füttert,
ist für sie quasi Gott.
Morgen läuft es gleich wie heute.
Wir sollten um 6 Uhr aufstehen.
Denn wir sind etwas langsam.
Und wir sollten
noch effizienter werden,
nicht herumtrödeln.
- (Barbara) We heard that.
Eine Person kümmert sich
um den Kocher für das Hundefutter
und bleibt auch dort.
Eine macht das Teewasser
und geht nicht weg.
Ich nenne jetzt keine Namen,
aber schaut wirklich,
dass ihr kontinuierlich neuen Schnee
in den Ofen hineinschaufelt,
damit die Flamme
immer gross genug bleibt.
Und das Andere -
das hatselbst mich erstaunt:
Die Hunde
haben eine wahnsinnige Energie.
Das ist zwar toll,
wenn es ums Rennen geht,
aber vor dem Start
kann es gefährlich werden.
Sie sind so aufgeladen am Morgen.
Es geht noch,
solange sie an der Nachtleine sind,
aber sobald ihr ihnen
das Laufgeschirr anzieht,
geht der Energiepegel hoch.
(Alle) Mhm.
Like we saw this morning.
Ballack war wahrscheinlich
nochnie in einen Streit verwickelt.
Er hat Cooper hart rangenommen.
Ich habe nicht gesehen,
wie es angefangen hat,
aber ich bin sicher,
Cooper hat ihn provoziert.
Und am Schluss
musste ich ihn den ganzen Tag
auf dem Schlitten hinterherziehen.
Passt von jetzt an auf am Morgen.
Bellen ist in Ordnung.
Wenn sie mit dem Schwanz wedeln
und glücklich sind, ist es okay.
Aber sobald ihr hört,
dass der Ton ändert,
wenn sie aggressiv werden
und ihre Freunde mustern:
"Was machst denn du?"
Wenn sie anfangen,
einander anzuschreien -
unterbindet es sofort.
Zeigt ihnen: Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Denn in einem nächsten Schritt
wird jemand verletzt.
Und wir sind aufgeschmissen,
wenn die Hälfte des Teams
bei mir in der Notfallbox landet.
Also ich jedenfalls.
Sonst habt ihr es gut gemacht.
Auch das Fahren.
Die Temperatur ist deutlich gefallen,
es sind jetzt eisige -20 °C.
* Sphärische Klänge *
(Barbara) Immer dieser Geruch
am Morgen auf leeren Magen ...
Die fünf Abenteurer
haben schon wieder verschlafen.
Sie sind fast 1 Std. zu spät dran.
Es ist schon fast 7 Uhr.
(Martina) Es knistert immerhin.
-(Armin) Schon fast geschafft.
(Martina) Super.
- Wir sind ein bisschen verspätet.
Man kann auch in der Wildnis
gut verschlafen.
Wir reden alle davon, wir kämen
ohne Handy, und am Schluss ...
(Martina) Ich besitze effektiv
keinen Wecker ausser dem Handy,
und wenn das nicht geht ...
(Michelle)
Und hell wird es auch nicht.
(Armin)Das sehen wir gleich.
- (Michelle) Noch etwas rüber.
Das ist gut. Holen wir
die Zeit wieder rein.- Locker.
Hast du gut geschlafen?
Wir machen heute
keine keine lange Mittagsrast,
denn wir müssen noch im Tageslicht
den grossen Hügel hochkommen.
Wir füllen die Thermosflaschen
und essen unterwegs ein Sandwich.
Heute steht die Königsetappe an
mit dem Aalistunturi,
dem höchsten Punkt der Tour -
einem Hügel
mit einem harten Aufstieg auf 200 m.
Es sieht gut aus.
Es ist jetzt etwa 8.30 Uhr.
Sie essen Frühstück,
das Zelt ist leergeräumt,
die Hunde wurden früh gefüttert,
so um 7 Uhr.
Ich bin wirklich erfreut
über diese Steigerung.
Jetzt muss ich mich
mit meinem Zelt beeilen,
damit ich nicht die lahme Ente bin!
* Bellen, Jaulen *
Auch das Anspannen
läuft heute schon viel besser.
Der hier ist der dickere.
So.
Komm!
* Knurren *
Hey, Dally! Fertig!
Fertig.
Dann nehme ich euch beide
halt auseinander.
Und wie geht es dem Patienten,
dem jungen Punk Cooper?
Er kann heute laufen.
Ich habe gestern
vielleicht etwas übertrieben.
Der Schnitt war nur etwa so gross.
Jetzt ist die Wunde
schon fast geschlossen.
Kein Blut.
Nur eine kleine Verletzung.
Aber du nimmst ihn in dein Team?
Ja. Ich will schauen, ob er beim
nächsten Stopp wirklich nicht hinkt.
Er liebt es zu rennen,
da wird man ihm nichts anmerken.
Er wird mir vorspielen,
dass alles gut ist.
(Barbara) Na, freust du dich?
Alles ist heute viel ruhiger
als gestern.
Eine Ruhe, die auch Barbara spürt,
die dreifache Mutter und Psychologin.
Ja, du bist ready, nicht wahr?
Als ich die Socken anzog,
kam mir wieder in den Sinn:
Hatte ich mal eine Krise,
ging ich so oft zum Hund und weinte.
Wenn sich meine Eltern
wieder mal stritten
und es zu Hause nicht so lief,
wie ich wollte.
Ich weinte ins Fell, bis alles
nass war. Das weiss ich noch.
Wir hatten auch so einen schwarzen.
Eine ähnliche Grösse wie Siska.
Ja, die letzten Jahre waren ...
schon tough.
Ich hätte
auch nie länger weggekonnt.
Mein Mann hatte ein Kavernom
und musste am Hirnstamm
und am Kleinhirn operiert werden.
Das war schon crazy.
V.a. für ihn,
und für uns alle auch.
Und ich war gerade
mit dem zweiten Kind schwanger.
Ich habe schon
ein wenig die Tendenz Ð
obwohl ich weiss, das sollte
man nicht -, zu verdrängen,
resp. ich bin sehr optimistisch,
manchmal auch etwas idealistisch.
Und ich glaube,
dass Trauer und negative Emotionen
auch mal Platz haben.
Dafür muss man sich Zeit lassen.
Das merkte ich gestern unterwegs.
Wir müssen schauen,
dass es sich nicht verwickelt.
* Sphärische, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Und dann geht es los -
auf die 40-km-Strecke
und dem Aalistunturi zum Schluss.
Er ist selbst für erfahrene Musher
eine Herausforderung.
* Sphärische, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Inzwischen sind sie
am dritten Tag unterwegs,
haben bei bis zu -20 °C
in der Kälte übernachtet,
sind bis zu 14 Std. auf den Beinen
und lassen sich täglich
auf Neues und Ungewohntes ein.
(Juho) Hier durch!
Langsam runterfahren.
Komm, Armin!
Juho zieht durch - er will
den angekündigten harten Anstieg
mit den Schweizern unbedingt
noch bei Tageslicht erreichen.
Noch bleiben 2 Std.
* Sphärische, abenteuerliche Klänge *
Deshalb gibt es heute
nur eine ganz kurze Pause,
damit sich die Hunde für die bevor-
stehende Anstrengung stärken können.
(Armin) Wir geben rechte Portionen.
- Ja, wegen des Sees.
Nun geht's über den See
und nachher den Hügel rauf.
Wir haben gestern gelernt, Armin,
dass du beim Füttern
eine Bindung zu den Hunden aufbaust,
darum gebe ich deinen Hunden nichts.
Vielen Dank.
Annie.
Mmh!
Fighter.
Ja! Und Winnie. Guten Appetit.
Martina, die HR-Managerin,
spürt inzwischen die Anstrengung.
Ich spüre es immer noch,
oder wieder.
Bisher ging es aber relativ gut.
Der Trail ging halt
immer wieder hoch und runter.
Jetzt gehen wir
über einen grossen See -
soweit ich weiss, sind Seen flach.
Wir sollten zu Mittag essen können
während der Fahrt über den See.
Mal schauen, wie das funktioniert.
Dann geht es buchstäblich
um die Wurst, auf den Hügel zu.
Die Hunde kennen keine Müdigkeit
und wollen weiter.
Jetzt ist wieder gut.
- Cool.
Jetzt geht es flach über den See,
glaube ich.
Und dann der letzte Aufstieg -
200 Höhenmeter.
Aber nicht wie gestern.
Da machten wir das auf einmal.
- Das macht viel aus.
Und fühlst du dich auch gut?
Die Hände?
Ja, die Hände sind schon verkrampft.
- Immer noch?
Ich muss immer dehnen.
- Das hilft?
Wenn du bewegst, hilft es?
- Ja.
Ich mache jeweils so.
Schau, mehr kann ich nicht.
- Krass. Oh, Mann.
Ich bringe sie nicht gerade hin.
- Mhm.
Ziemlich krass.
- Ja.
Ich muss heute Abend
Wärmecreme einstreichen.
Gegen diese Buckel
muss man öffnende Übungen machen.
Deshalb drehe ich mich immer so.
- Ja.
Ich bewundere dich,
wie du das machst.
Mega.
* Helle, perlende Musik,
Trommelschläge *
Super!
Gut!
* Jauchzer *
Damit die Huskys
nicht zu schnell werden,
müssen die Teilnehmer
dauernd auf der Bremse stehen.
Langsam! He.
Bravo!
* Jauchzer *
So schön!
* Treibende, pulsierende Klänge *
Nach dem See
zieht Juho gleich weiter.
Bereits setzt das Dämmerlicht ein.
Das Gelände wird immer unebener.
Seit 4 Std. stehen sie jetzt schon
auf dem Schlitten,
ein körperlicher
und koordinativer Kraftakt für alle.
* Schrei *
(Englisch) Alles in Ordnung.
Nichts passiert.
Silvia, vergiss nicht zu bremsen.
Bist du eingeschlafen?
Ich habe schon gebremst, ich bin
auf der Metallplatte gestanden.
Aber du bist vielleicht
schon etwas schläfrig unterwegs.
Die Bremse benutzen, die Bremse.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Das war ein Weckruf.
Ja, genau.
* Dunkle, sphärische Klänge, Jaulen *
Erst gegen 15 Uhr erreichen sie
den Anstieg zum Aalistunturi.
Fast bei Tageslicht.
* Er lacht. *
Fast. Wir sind schon weit.
(Silvia) Wie weit noch?
Jetzt geht's nur noch hoch,
und dann sind wir da.
Kein flaches Stück mehr
von jetzt an.
1 Std.?
- Genau.
* Leises Hundejaulen *
* Dunkle, sphärische Klänge *
Den 200 m steilen Anstieg
müssen sie nun im Dunkeln bewältigen,
was die Sache nicht leichter macht.
* Dunkle, sphärische Klänge *
Dieser steile Streckenabschnitt
gehört auch
zu einem Langstreckenrennen,
das Juho und andere Schlittenprofis
mit ihren Hunden bewältigen.
* Dunkle, sphärische Klänge *
* Jauchzer *
Ho, warten. Stopp.
Es war herrlich.
Und dieses Gefühl,
wenn man oben ist. Mega cool!
Es ist so schön:
Man rennt zwischendurch mit,
und dann steigt man wieder drauf
und fährt mit den Hunden mit.
Und die haben Kraft -
unwahrscheinlich.
Es ist so steil,
und die ziehen einen einfach rauf.
Das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Ihr Starken!
Wie gern die schuften,
das ist beeindruckend.
Die sehen den Hügel
und man sieht ihnen an,
dass sie sich darauf freuen,
den Schlitten hochzuziehen.
Das ist beeindruckend.
Alle haben es geschafft.
Am Morgen hatte ich noch eine Krise,
aber es war ja jetzt
nur noch ein letzter Hügel.
Hätte es mehrere solche gehabt,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich
einen Sitzstreik gemacht.
Jetzt bin ich schon ... am Anschlag.
(Michelle) Kannst du mehr?
- (Martina) Ich halte ihn.
Trotz Müdigkeit
packen sie nun alle an
und unterstützen sich gegenseitig -
keine Spur von Chaos mehr.
Immer noch nicht gut?
- Nein, hier muss es wirklich ...
Ich glaube,
oben- und dann untendurch.
Wenn sie ziehen, hält es ja hier.
Ich meine: Wir lassen es so.
Danke, cool.
Wir haben es zusammen geschafft.
Ich habe einfach Kopfschmerzen.
Das bekomme ich schnell,
wenn ich zu wenig getrunken habe.
Normalerweise
trinke ich 2-3 l pro Tag.
Unsere Thermosflasche hat 0,75 l -
und jetzt ist noch was drin.
Jetzt gibt's noch ein Mäntelchen.
Das haben wir auch im Programm.
Jetzt vertraue ich ihnen.
Es ist der dritte Tag.
Und mit nur wenigen Ratschlägen
funktionieren sie jetzt
gut als Team.
Es gibt keinen Grund zur Sorge mehr.
Sie haben
die Hunde richtig festgemacht,
graben Löcher für die Hunde,
helfen sich gegenseitig.
Jetzt warten wir nur noch,
bis das Essen fertig ist.
Wir könnten im Zelt auch eine
Heuunterlage gegen die Kälte machen,
wenn wir genug Heu haben.
So.
Oh, lasst sie schlafen.
* Dunkle, sphärische Klänge *
* Ausatmen *
* Sphärischer Gesang *
Für die alte Hundedame Chess
gibt es heute
eine willkommene Überraschung:
Statt in der Kälte bei -20 °C
darf sie mit im Zelt übernachten.
Süss, schau.
Martina weiss, wie's geht.
Sie weiss, wie's geht. So ist dir
wohl.- (Armin) Chess, du Verwöhnte!
(Martina) Ich hatte auch schon
Vierbeiner im Bett.- Cool.
Hündchen, schlaft gut.
Bis morgen.
* Sphärische Klänge *
6 Uhr - Tagwacht.
* Helle, perlende Klänge *
Ja, es ist Schnee, kein Regen.
- Nicht wahr?
Das Schöne ist, dass man sich
am Morgen nicht kämmen muss.
Man zieht einfach
die Mütze wieder an.
Ich bin ziemlich
nach links gerutscht.- Ja.
Sag ihr bitte,
sie soll mehr nach rechts.
Du kannst nicht alles haben.
- Pfüdi!
Ja, also ...
An diesem Tag liegt die längste Tour
vor ihnen: über 50 km.
Und nach dem steilen Aufstieg von
gestern eine schwierige Abfahrt.
Packen!
- (Armin) Wo hast du deine Jacke?
Die Abfahrt ist selbst
für Juho anspruchsvoll.
Er sorgt sich um Silvia.
Wie geht es dir? Sei ehrlich.
Ich habe besser geschlafen.
Mir war warm genug.
Ich glaube, das schaffe ich heute.
Du und die Hunde
müssen einfach sicher runterkommen.
Kein Grund, etwas zu riskieren.
Du sagst es mir einfach,
du bist direkt hinter mir.
Sag mir,
wenn du eine Pause brauchst.
Wir versuchen, den Tag zu geniessen,
und müssen uns nicht beeilen.
Let's go!
Im Team gibt es eine, die sich
auf die lange Abfahrt richtig freut:
die ehemalige Bobfahrerin Michelle.
Das ist gut. Mir gefällt das.
Schnell, aber trotzdem sicher.
Die Sicherheit der Hunde
steht im Vordergrund.
Es ist wichtig,
dass den Hunden nichts passiert.
(Flüsternd) Nicht wahr? Ja.
Ja.
Du und dein Team
habt die ganze Arbeit gemacht.
Anny, Schätzeli, aufstehen!
Wir sind parat.
* Bellen *
Ja.
Martina dagegen
hatte gestern Kopfschmerzen.
Das ist fies.
Ich habe sehr gut geschlafen.
Wir hatten einen Hund im Zelt,
vielleicht war das der Grund.
Ich konnte auch durchschlafen.
Ich habe wieder Energie getankt.
Es geht mir gut, und ich bin
gespannt, wie es mir am Abend geht.
Alle machen sich bereit
für die Abfahrt.
Barbara stimmt sich auf ihre Art ein.
Wollen wir nochmals jodeln, Leute?
- Ja, du!
Vielleicht machen die Hunde mit.
* Barbara jodelt. *
* Armin jauchzt. *
Wie sie alle geschaut haben.
* Bellen *
* Barbara jodelt weiter,
die Hunde bellen. *
Armin sorgt sich
um die Pfoten seiner Hunde.
Am Anfang hatte ich Angst,
dass ich zu fest ...
Jetzt ziehe ich sie fest an,
und wenn sie rennen,
fliegen sie trotzdem weg.
Man muss einfach schauen,
dass man alle Grössen hat.
So, Chess, komm!
Hey, ich muss dir
diese Pantoffeln anziehen.
Sie ist ein richtiges Weibchen.
Ich hatte auch eines. Es ist
das Beste, das man haben kann.
Hier haben wir
das verwöhnte Tierchen.
Ein echter Leader,
sie ist elf Jahre alt.
Die geniesst das richtig.
Und jetzt? Passt es?
Hm? Es ist gut, ja.
Das ist eine kleine Hilfe,
damit auf der langen Abfahrt
weder der Gruppe noch den Hunden
etwas passiert.
Come on! Come on, guy!
Wenn der Fuss von der Bremse rutscht
oder sie sogar runterfallen
und die Kontrolle
über den Schlitten verlieren,
dann wirken diese Ketten unter
den Kufen wie eine starke Bremse,
und der Schlitten wird nicht
in die Hunde hineinprallen.
So spielt es keine Rolle,
ob sie runterfallen.
Diese Ketten hier braucht es,
damit niemandem etwas passiert.
* Treibende, abenteuerliche Musik *
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
2 km Abfahrt, 200 Höhemeter,
durch Bäume, zwischen
verschneiten Felsen hindurch.
Dieses Mal bei Tageslicht
und hohem Tempo.
* Treibende, abenteuerliche Musik *
* Unverständliche Anweisungen
von Juho *
Alles, was sie bis jetzt
gelernt haben, ist nun gefordert -
und eine gute Portion Mut.
* Treibende, mystische Musik *
* Treibende, abenteuerliche Musik *
* Jauchzer *
Das war eine verrückte Abfahrt.
Ich hab's geschafft!
Der Rest des Tages fühlt sich jetzt
wie ein Spaziergang an.
Die Bremsketten halfen.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Vielen Dank für deine Tipps -
bezüglich der Gewichtsverlagerung.
Ja, du bist nicht runtergefallen.
Das war kein einfacher Hügel,
auch ich spüre ihn.
Wenn man will, kann man alles tun -
auch mit einer Krankheit.
Ich bin stolz.
Viele andere können das auch.
Man muss sich trauen und Mut haben.
Ich glaube, ich hatte hier Mut.
Es war super.
* Hecheln *
Für mich hätte es ruhig
etwas schneller sein können.
Aber es ist wichtig,
dass auch die Hunde sicher sind.
Am Anfang ... Die sind so geladen.
Die wären davon, und wir hätten
keine Chance gehabt, sie zu halten.
Ich finde es super, dass Juho
diese Ketten rangemacht hat,
die zusätzlich gebremst haben.
Es war sehr gut.
* Jaulen *
Er sagte vorher,
das habe er noch nie gemacht.
Und er hat mich umarmt.
Ein Finne
zeigt sonst nicht solche Emotionen.
Aber er ist ziemlich stolz auf das,
was er mit uns gemacht hat.
Bis ein Finne aus sich rauskommt,
braucht es was.
Es war wirklich sehr schön.
Es hat gepasst.
Ich erinnere mich noch:
Letztes Jahr,
beim Lappland-Quest-Rennen,
haben sogar die Profis
nachher gesagt,
dieser Hügel hätte sie geschlaucht.
Und die haben jahrelange Erfahrung.
Zehn Punkte für alle hier.
Yes.
Schön! Geniess den Rest des Tages.
Gut gemacht.
Die Strecke an diesem Tag
ist noch lang.
Aber der Anfangsstress ist gewichen.
* Treibende, abenteuerliche Musik *
Selbst Martina, die HR-Managerin, die
sonst gern alles unter Kontrolle hat,
entdeckt neue Seiten an sich.
Ich bin gedankenfrei,
grüble nicht an irgendetwas rum,
was ich sonst häufig mache.
Es ist ein Moment des Abschaltens.
Wir sind gerade auf einem See.
Nur schon die Vorstellung,
dass wir auf einem See fahren,
ist irrsinnig schön.
Es ist einfach eine Weite ...
... in der man sich
sehr klein fühlt.
Die Natur ist so wunderschön, da
muss man gar nicht so viel denken.
Einfach nur dankbar sein für das,
was man hier erleben kann.
* Treibende Musik *
Die Route führt über den See,
den sie erst gestern überquert haben.
* Energische Musik *
Inzwischen sind die Schweizer
mit ihren Hunden
zu einem Team zusammengewachsen.
* Energische Musik *
Nach zwei Fahrtstunden
ein Stoppsignal von Tourguide Juho.
Davon hatte er der Gruppe
nichts verraten.
Ich passe auf die Hunde auf.
Ich mache das schon.
Legt mir
die Snacks für die Hunde raus.
Ich habe keine mehr.
Sie hat noch.
Well ...
Die Leute
von der Gemeinde Pasmajärvi
haben von unserem Abenteuer erfahren
und haben
eine kleine Überraschung bereit.
Ich schaue zu den Hunden
und schicke die Gruppe hinüber
zur alten Mühle.
Ich habe so eine Ahnung,
dass sie da etwas Leckeres erwartet.
Pasmajärvi ist eine kleine Gemeinde
mitten in den Wäldern Lapplands
mit 31 Einwohnern, verteilt
auf 8,3 km2 - am gleichnamigen See.
Umso grösser der Stolz darüber,
den Schweizern ihre Sehenswürdigkeit,
die alte Mühle, zu zeigen,
wo sie Essen und Musik
vorbereitet haben.
So schön, mega.
So schön!
* Jubel *
* Sanfter, mystischer Gesang,
Stimmengewirr *
Wir haben nur
etwas Kleines für euch.
Nur etwas Symbolisches.
Danke vielmals.
* Fröhliche Akkordeonmusik *
Barbara bittet Armin zum Tanz.
Ich bin kaputt.
- Jöö.
Vielen Dank.
- So schön.
Mit diesem Schuhwerk.
- Man kommt kaum vom Fleck.
Ihr habt das elegant gemacht.
- Hay, ay, ay.
Die Leute aus Pasmajärvi haben
stundenlang lokalen Lachs geräuchert.
Die Gruppe erlebt die traditionelle
finnische Gastfreundschaft.
Wow!
Es ist alles nass.
- Das macht nichts.
Is it okay, if we put ...
Ich möchte gerne mal zwei Monate
lang in so einer Hütte leben.
Zwei Monate hier draussen ...
- Lädst du uns auch ein?
Ja, nacheinander.
Michelle, du wärst die Erste.
Ich nehme das Grösste.
Reich beschenkt.
- Genau.
Zum Wohl.
(Alle) Ooole!
(Armin) Das ist heiss.
- Ein solch intensiver Geschmack.
Der Hecht ist auch irrsinnig.
- Der Geschmack ist unglaublich.
Die Familie vermisst man,
aber nicht stark.
Man hat gar nie Zeit,
daran zu denken.
Das stimmt.
Ich muss ehrlich sein:
Das geniesse ich jetzt für mich.
Am Abend denke ich kurz daran,
und das wissen sie auch.
Meine Frau weiss ganz genau,
dass ich das geniesse.
Es ist nicht entscheidend, ob sie
etwas von mir hört oder nicht.
Sie hat Freude,
wenn sie etwas hört - wenn man kann.
Aber wir haben ja kein Handy.
Also auf das Bett
freue ich mich schon.
Diese Schneehügel ...
Mit der Zeit, wenn sie
am Rücken oder an der Hüfte drücken
und der Schnee gefroren ist ...
Ich freue mich mehr
auf den Komfort eines Bettes,
aber sonst vermisse ich nichts.
Ich hätte nichts
gegen ein etwas komfortableres WC.
Nur schon eine Holzkonstruktion.
Damit man die Oberschenkelmuskeln
nicht so anspannen muss,
dass man umplumpst,
wenn man nicht mehr kann.
Denn dann hat man ein Problem.
Auf Wiedersehen. Wir müssen weiter.
Danke schön. Tschau.
Vielen Dank. Das war für uns
eine sehr schöne Überraschung.
So kind. Thank you.
14 Uhr - noch über 30 km
in der Dunkelheit vor ihnen.
* Energische Trommelmusik *
Die Temperaturen liegen bei -15 °C.
Mit über 15 km/h ziehen die Hunde
die Gruppe durch den Wald.
Für sie gibt es kein Halten mehr.
Dann ein Schreckmoment.
* Finnischer Ausruf *
(Verschiedene) Nein, nein.
Beim Überqueren einer Strasse
werden die Hunde in der Dunkelheit
fast von einem Bagger überrollt.
Alles ist noch einmal gut gegangen.
Und Armin bekommt an diesem Tag
noch einmal die geballte Kraft
seines Hundegespanns zu spüren.
Armin ging der Schlitten ab.
Jetzt konnte ich die Hunde
festhalten. Es geht wieder.
Meine Lampe fiel zu Boden.
Ich mache so und ...
Okay.
Umgekehrt.
* Bellen *
So sieht es besser aus.
Jetzt haben wir
den verrücktesten Hügel vor uns.
Vorher war auch ein Anstieg,
bei dem ich
für ein paar Minuten festsass
und den Schlitten rausziehen musste.
Aber dieser Hügel
ist wirklich steil.
Wir machen oben sicher eine Pause.
Dann kommen wieder die Ketten ran,
um zu bremsen.
Und wir fahren runter zur Hütte.
* Dynamische Musik *
Seit über 6 Std. unterwegs.
Vor ihnen liegt der letzte
grosse Aufstieg der Tour.
* Anfeuerungsrufe von Juho *
* Barbara juchzt. *
(Barbara) Super.
Bravo. Sackstark!
Sackstark.
* Winseln *
(Juho) Noch eine Abfahrt.
(Barbara) Ich wünsche mir,
dass dieser Traum nie aufhört.
(Juho) Ich finde es okay,
dass das der letzte Anstieg war.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Aber mir gefällt einfach alles.
Nein, kaputt bin ich gar nicht.
Eher etwas enttäuscht,
als wir oben waren. Es ist so schön.
Ich geniesse es,
diese Zeit zu haben.
Zeit, um zu träumen
und Lebensvisionen zu konstruieren.
Ich habe alle Aufgaben vergessen.
Das ist verrückt.
Das gibt es sonst kaum.
Das ist krass.
Wenn ich nach Hause komme
und überlege, was alles kommt ...
Aber in diesen Tagen
habe ich nie daran gedacht.
Das habe ich noch nie
so krass erlebt.
Wie eine Art Schnitt.
Jetzt bin ich hier in dieser Welt.
Es könnte mir
nichts Besseres passieren.
Es ist etwas vom Besten, was ich
bisher in meinem Leben gemacht habe.
Ich werde bestimmt sehr oft an
diese Momente und Tage zurückdenken.
Ich werde versuchen, die Qualität
der Ruhe und der Stille mitzunehmen.
Dieses Im-Moment-Sein.
Ich wünsche mir, dass ich das
in meinen Alltag mitnehmen kann.
Dass ich den Moment geniessen
und im Jetzt leben kann
und nicht schon an 1'000 Sachen
voraus und an Termine denke.
Und diese Freude,
die auch die Hunde haben.
Wenn sie rennen,
bedeutet das alles für sie.
Sie leben im Moment und geben alles.
Und dann sind sie zufrieden.
Nicht wahr?
* Ruhige Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Die Tage alleine mit den Hunden
in der Wildnis Lapplands
neigen sich langsam dem Ende zu.
* Treibende Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Gegen 19 Uhr erreichen sie
ihren letzten Rastplatz am See.
* Befehlsrufe von Juho *
Stopp. Ho!
Alle haben es durchgestanden -
die Hunde und die Abenteurerinnen.
Das hat sie schon
ziemlich herausgefordert.
Das war sicher am Limit.
Und selbst für mich
war es nicht einfach.
Sie mussten bestimmt
raus aus ihrer Komfortzone.
Ja, ich glaube, das passte.
Entschuldigung. Jetzt muss ich das
nochmals wechseln, Schatz.
Es hat super geklappt, nicht wahr?
Jetzt bin ich extrem zufrieden.
Eine ganz tiefe Zufriedenheit.
Ich glaube,
ich habe etwas von ihnen gelernt:
dass man gegenseitig
vollstes Vertrauen haben muss.
Egal, ob Mensch oder Tier,
in jeder Beziehung.
Es ist eine Beziehung,
die du mit diesen Hunden hast.
Vertrauen ist wichtig.
Ich bewundere sie.
Sie haben so viel Energie.
Und diese Faszination.
Sie sind so begeistert.
Ihnen ist es egal, wie schwer
du bist und wie viel Gepäck du hast.
Die machen einfach. Geradeaus.
Genial.
Ich habe mich definitiv verliebt.
Das kann man so sagen.
Ich möchte nicht an morgen denken.
Ich habe heute kurz daran gedacht.
Das war nicht schön.
Das war emotional.
* Schniefen *
* Schluchzen *
Es ist verrückt,
innerhalb von vier Tagen
so eine Bindung erleben zu können,
so eine Liebe zu bekommen ...
... und zu geben.
* Jaulen *
* Mystischer Gesang *
* Gefühlvolle, melancholische Musik *
Ein letztes Mal aufstehen,
ein letztes Mal die Hunde einspannen,
die ihnen ans Herz gewachsen sind
und ihnen erst das unvergessliche
Erlebnis ermöglicht haben.
* Mystische Musik *
(Juho) Oi, oi, oi.
Juho hat Vertrauen
in junge Hunde gesetzt.
Etwa in die einjährige Mayday.
Und andere,
von denen er nicht wusste,
wie sie das Abenteuer meistern.
* Heulen *
Sie haben sich viel besser gehalten
als erwartet.
Gestern war verrückt.
Aber sie haben durchgehalten.
Oft können Hunde einen Tag lang
eine harte Strecke rennen.
Du siehst erst am nächsten Tag,
ob du übertrieben hast,
ob es zu schnell oder zu weit war.
Mayday hat alles gefressen -
am Morgen und am Abend.
Jetzt sieht sie aus,
als hätte sie gar nichts gemacht.
Das war die richtige Entscheidung
und auch das richtige Tempo.
Ich war überrascht, dass ich sie
nicht in die Kiste nehmen musste.
Das waren mehr als 50 km heute
und einige harte Aufstiege.
Es freut mich wirklich, dass meine
Hunde immer noch so gut drauf sind.
Mayday.
* Er spricht finnisch. *
Wärmen wir die Girls etwas auf.
Das ist die richtige Einstellung.
Was bedeuten dir deine Hunde?
To me?
Das werde ich viel gefragt.
Die Antwort
ist immer noch nicht einfach.
Es ist ein Mix aus einem Haustier
und einem Sportkollegen.
Wie in einem Sportteam.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
ich sei der Coach,
sie die Athleten oder die Kollegen.
Aber im Nachtlager
sind sie dann eher wie die Tiere,
für die ich sorge.
Es kommt darauf an.
Aber ich würde sie trotzdem nicht
einfach als Haustiere bezeichnen.
Mit denen macht man nicht
so was Verrücktes.
Man wirft ihnen auf dem Sofa
einen Ball zu.
Ich glaube,
eigentlich sind sie Teamkollegen.
Du schaffst es
durch keinen Sturm ohne sie
oder kommst diese Hügel nicht hoch.
Aber sie brauchen dich auch -
für das Essen. Du sorgst für sie.
Ready?
Jetzt könnt ihr euch
etwas entspannen.
* Gefühlvolle Musik *
Heute Morgen schon
hat es mir das Herz zusammengezogen
beim Gedanken,
dass wir uns
von ihnen verabschieden müssen.
Das geht einem nahe.
So schöne Tiere.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Yep.
* Sanfte Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Für eine kurze Zeit
aus den Verpflichtungen des Alltags
ausbrechen.
Fünf Menschen,
die sich nicht gekannt haben,
sind zu einem Team geworden.
* Epische Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Sie mussten lernen,
sie mussten sich überwinden,
sie mussten kämpfen.
Und sie haben alle etwas gewonnen.
Zeit.
Zeit, wieder einmal zu spüren,
wer sie sind und was sie wollen -
in der Weite und der Ruhe Lapplands.
* Sanfte Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Und so endet dieses Abenteuer dort,
wo es vor fünf Tagen begonnen hat:
auf der Ranch von Juho.
* Dynamische Musik
mit mystischem Gesang *
Mit fünf Menschen, die ihrem Leben
ein neues Kapitel hinzugefügt haben.
Jetzt könnt ihr ziehen.
Jetzt seid ihr zu Hause. Hey.
Und Fremde zu Freunden gemacht hat.
* Gefühlvolle Musik *
Ich sagte, ich gehe jedes Jahr.
Merci.
Es war herrlich.
* Dynamische, tragende Musik *
Denn manchmal ist es an der Zeit, das
zu tun, wovon man immer geträumt hat.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
M. Gregoris, T. Morana, D. Zacheo,